on va pas jusqu'au ce qu'ils voient
fêter noël ensemble en famille ça va
être super tu es venu
yann pour les vacances à réfléchis pas
je fais pas je t'ai déjà dit prouvez moi
je peux rester ici rend non ici soit
restée vous allez pas commencer un
personne d'arrêt cgc mon père peut pas
laisser tout ce n'est pas tout seul mais
on doit être adaptée au nez aux jeunes
je pense qu'il va nous trouver son père
noël tu croit encore au père noël petits
enfants mais rafa mais qu'est ce que tu
racontes même bien sûr comprendre au
père noël
c'est un mot très grandes inquiétudes et
dès maintenant on va rater le camp de
ski le ski c'est pour les mauviettes
oui c'est pas un cadeau mais pardon non
[Musique]
la première équipe qui aura franchi la
ligne d'arrivée qui aura gagné les spams
je sais pas j'ai rien compris
les voisins excusez nous empêche comme
toujours un petit peu les mêmes qui font
les problèmes pour qu'ils se prennent
ces gens je jouais toujours sauver
lycéens bouyer tout ça parce qu'ils ont
gagné trois fois d'affilée que ça va mal
se vidèrent on vend le bois ce truc est
de la thune ludo on gagne à faire un
truc ensemble en famille bin non non non
pas s'afficher comme sa famille et lui
[Musique]
identité arabe ajouté
gérez vous cela d'accord audi nation je
suis pas foutu de vie pareille mais tu
nous emmerdes avec tes principes s'est
promenée noël ce que tu passes avec tes
petits enfants mais je te préviens c'est
le père noël qui te dit il voulait aller
au mont blanc si tu le caches chose
retourner dans ma vie jamais gravi des
sommets mais être là aujourd'hui avec
toi pour moi c'est le plus beau wes
madame des choix lieu
vous devez les coûts techniques aller
je lève mon verre pour ces super
vacances de noël
je vois un changement stratégique et qui
tiennent au brésil tonnes
maman